un mec qui a été tué là dedans il ya dix
ans vous ne trouvez pas que cette
étrange caudan dans les deux cas cinq
personnes présentes dans les deux cas un
enfant de 10 ans
oui c'est très étrange parce qu'en 1955
quelqu'un a été assassiné le même
c'était aussi un 12 avril nico qu'est ce
qui t'arrive
qu'ils ont commencé à lui faire peur lui
parlant de ce meurtre à la station
service
peut-être pas une menace mais un
avertissement
vous savez ce qui s'est passé je vous
conseille de laisser tomber j'ai besoin
de savoir qu'est ce que vous savez cet
endroit avant qu'il soit vous en 76 y
avait pas de boutiques y avait que les
pompes à essence et des bureaux mais
quelque chose a mal tourné tout tout a
mal tourné on va finir par le retrouver
l'histoire n'a absolument aucun sens je
te parle d'une séquence numérique
à chaque fois tout ça
les nombres demande pas dit
[Musique]
j'ai tome dames c'est pas normal le
schéma va se répéter